[Music]
[Laughter]
we are so involved in our search and
research
that this slipped in on us how are you
doing hope you're doing well i'm here
with
uh my friend and uh colleague in
ministry pastor stephen border president
of secret sentencing i'm c.a murray this
of course is i'd like to know
and this is our our time where we get to
answer your questions from the word of
god
we want to jump right into
letting you know how you can become a
part of this experience by
emailing us
at tv thumb tv tv at some tv.org
tv at some tv.org
is the
uh
place where you can get your questions
looked at and answered our our pile
there i say our stack is becoming rather
impressive
and
we will try to get to as many as we can
from the word of god we promise you to
always answer them from the word of god
and
uh to do so as god gives us strength to
do so pastor uh if you want to pray we
can launch right out it's good to have
you here i've got papers all over the
place uh because that's the kind of guy
i am i guess i have papers all over the
place the paper man
well let's have a word of prayer and
then we'll go to our first question
father in heaven we thank you now for
the opportunity of spending these few
minutes
uh digging into your word and answering
some questions that people have asked
we asked lord that for the guidance of
your holy spirit
that our answers might be in harmony
with the bible
and when we don't have a direct answer
in the bible that we might be able to
take principles
that apply
and answer the questions we thank you
lord for the privilege of prayer thank
you for answering our prayer for we ask
it in jesus name amen amen amen amen
okay this question came up
several years ago when we started i'd
like to know
but it's been so long that i think that
it would be a good idea to answer it
once more because it's come up a couple
couple of times
this is from shem first time i've ever
encountered someone whose name is shen
he lives in kenya and current well
actually he's from kenya and lives in
poland
but this is his question
since i moved abroad
i have been thinking if i died
how do i want my remains transferred
back home
thus begging the question of cremation
is cremation biblical
and can it be practiced by christians
slash adventists
we love you
so much
at some tv
and glory to god that we can now access
your platforms may god bless you so the
question is regarding cremation
whether cremation is biblical
and of course i don't think that the
bible directly addresses the issue of
cremation does it
i don't know if any text that that would
give us something we can sort of plant
our feed on we are
we are a proof text church we tend not
to put our foot down unless there's a
text under it to put your foot down on
and we've proceeded that way i would say
this because that question has come up a
good friend of mine his wife passed just
this week and just this past wednesday
she was cremated
she was a nurse practitioner very
faithful member of the church
my mind says
this the bible tells me
earth to earth ashes to ashes
i don't think it is any more difficult
for god to reconstruct a body that is
decomposed
over
a number of years number of decades
however long it takes the body to
decompose
my uh
mother-in-law was funeralized today in
panama they don't do
you know the elaborate preparing of the
body they put the body in a box and put
in the ground
i don't think it's any more difficult
for god to deal with a body that was uh
decomposed that way or thrown into the
sea
or or cremated
god who who began it all out of nothing
can
recreate uh out of nothing if he wishes
to do so so i don't think it poses any
problem for god
um
so then it's left up to your opinion i
don't think it's not
biblical or biblical because the bible
doesn't state it specifically so what
we're giving is our sanctified judgment
but um i don't really when i was younger
in the ministry i had a problem with it
but i didn't really have any biblical
basis for my problem i don't at this
point in my life
okay
um i did a little research into the
practice of cremation
uh in different religious traditions
and
according to jewish tradition it is
forbidden to cremate someone most mostly
on the basis of rabbinical laws
a person who is cremated cannot be
buried in a jewish cemetery
and according to jewish law the body
must be buried in the earth
among hindus
this i'm getting directly from the
internet hindus place little value on
the body itself
they see the body as a prison for the
soul
one that generates attachments and
desires that prevent forward progress
towards freedom
therefore in hindu funerals the role of
cremation is to sever the ties of the
soul to the body that it is leaving
freeing it to move toward mukti which is
uh nirvana right but again that that's
based on an incorrect understanding of
what soul and body is sure yeah sure
yeah
so
i i've written a few things here that i
think would help
from a biblical perspective
as a principle
first of all genesis 2 verse 7 says that
man is made out of dust yes god made man
his body anyway out of the dust of the
ground
and when adam sinned god said dust you
are
and to dust
you shall return yes
psalm 104 verse 29 says
speaking about god you hide your face
they are troubled
you take away their breath
they die
and return to their dust
now
the bible tells us that um
the bible gives a descript description
of the resurrected body
in first corinthians chapter 15 you
might want to read that first
corinthians 15
verses 50 through 54
uh tells us what the resurrected body is
going to be like
and then i have a few little extra
thoughts here okay
this is a text that i repeated so many
many times
at my last church before i went into
conference work i did 117 funerals
and uh
at most of them if not all of them we
did first corinthians 15 beginning at
verse
what do you want to pick it up um 50
at verse 50
now now this i say brethren that flesh
and blood cannot inherit the kingdom of
god nor does corruption inherit
incorruption behold i tell you a mystery
we shall not all sleep but we shall all
be changed in a moment in the twinkling
of an eye at the last trumpet for the
trumpet shall sound and the dead will be
raised incorruptible and we shall be
changed for this corruption for this
corruptible must put on incorruption and
this mortal must put on immortality so
when this corruptible has put on
incorruption and this mortal has put on
immortality then
shall be brought to pass the saying that
is written death is swallowed up in
victory
so the resurrected body will be an
incorruptible and immortal body
but it's still going to be a physical
body yes uh because where our body is
going to be made
into the likeness of the glorified body
of jesus in fact let's read that
philippians chapter 3 and verse 21.
philippians chapter 3 and verse 21
tells us that our body will be
transformed into the likeness of the
body of jesus philippians chapter 3
verse 21 who will transform our lowly
body that it may be conformed to his
glorious body according to the working
by which he is able even to subdue all
things to himself
okay so our lowly body be will be
transformed into the likeness of
christ's glorified body
now after the resurrection did jesus
have a real body do we have any evidence
in the bible that he had a flesh and
blood body he ate well that's um
maybe luke 24 36.
and
all the way through verse 43 maybe
luke 24 36 to 43
luke
36.
alrighty
luke 24
and i'm at verse 36
now as they said these things jesus
himself stood in the midst of them and
said to them peace to you
but they were terrified and frightened
and supposed that they had seen a spirit
and he said to them why are you troubled
and why do why do doubts arise in your
hearts behold my hands and my feet
that it is i myself handle me and see
for a spirit does not have flesh and
bones as you see i have and verse 40
when he had said this he showed them his
hands and his feet but while they
still did not believe for joy and
marveled he said to them
have you any food here so they gave him
a piece of broiled fish and some
honeycomb and he took it and ate in
their presence
so his body had feet
his body
had flesh and bones
his body had hands
and he ate food yes which means that he
must have had a digestive system
so
is our resurrected body going to be a
physical body yes yes it is yes but now
i have this phenomenal statement from
ellen white which i think would is going
to help us
um
with the pro with the issue of uh
cremation
this is a statement that is not well
known i don't think in the church
it comes from
the book heaven page 40.
it's actually manuscript 76 1900.
and this is how it reads
our personal identity is preserved in
the resurrection
and here comes the key point though not
the same particles of matter or material
substance as went into the grave
so in other words god doesn't have to
recoup every little particle of matter
that went into the grave correct
she continues the wondrous works of god
are a mystery to man
the spirit
the character of man the spirit is the
character of man is returned to god
there to be preserved
in the resurrection every man will have
his own character
god in his own time will call forth the
dead giving again the breath of life
and bidding the dry bones live the same
form will come forth
but it will be free from disease and
every defect
it
lives again
bearing the same individuality of
features so that friend will recognize
friend
and now this is a key portion
there is no law of god in nature
which shows that god gives back the same
identical particles of matter which
compose the body before death
god shall give the righteous dead a body
that will please him
and then comes this very interesting
statement paul illustrates this subject
by the kernel of grain sown in the field
they the planted kernel decays
like when a person dies
but there comes forth a new kernel
the natural substance in the grain that
decays is never raised as before
but god giveth the body as it hath
pleased him
a much finer material will compose the
human body for it is a new creation a
new birth it is sown a natural body it
is raised a spiritual body yes so the
bottom line is if we're cremated
we're not going to get the same
particles of matter back anyway
precisely so uh in my opinion
uh if i should die before the lord comes
and i'm not saying that everybody out
there needs to do the way that i planned
but i think that cremation is a good
exercise in stewardship
because a funeral will cost you probably
20 times
what cremation costs i think so and so
instead of spending twenty thousand
dollars on a funeral you know you can
get a cremation for fifteen hundred two
thousand now i'm hoping and praying that
i'll be alive when jesus comes
but if not
i don't see any principle that would
forbid
cremation yes as long as you're not
doing it for hindu reasons
[Laughter]
which we don't
so um you know we don't have a death
saith the lord in the bible don't
cremate or do cremate but i think in the
light of this statement by all white
that we're not going to get the same
particles of matter back and you
wouldn't want the same part no because
they're diseased right yeah so it's
immaterial you know and so cremation i
don't think is a violation of divine
principle no
well said
okay well i hope that that helps
i wish i had a bible verse that i could
give you but i think in principle
this question we have answered
now here's another interesting question
and this one is uh
comes from
president say from michael
and this is how it reads is it wrong to
keep animals such as goats cows and
chickens for the sake of business when
you are an adventist who believes in the
health message
please help this has really troubled me
what is the stance of the spirit of
prophecy in the bible your positive
response will be highly appreciated
so
how do we deal you know i don't think
the bible addresses this one
particularly either no the closest thing
we have is when uh christ sent the um
the uh uh
demons into the pigs and pigs right down
the hill and and um
destroyed themselves
uh right where they belonged but
and that is true be because uh
uh
hebrew herdsmen should not be handling
pigs or dealing with racism and they
were jews and and they were jews so uh
they shouldn't have even been involved
in that enterprise for other reasons
than the fact that they were just uh uh
meat they were they were unclean animals
they should they should not be even
touched let alone uh you know taken care
of that way um i can't think of a text
nothing comes to my mind that would lay
squarely on top of this particular
question
the reason we don't
we preach vegetarianism is because
the
animal world has been so
polluted and so
[Music]
dealt with over the years that it's just
not healthy to eat
um
there are those who raise organic
animals and and organic chickens and
whatnot um
i don't know patsy i'm kind of stumped
on this one a little bit i i you know it
as an enterprise i i know of an
adventist who has a large farm he's the
first elderly church in um in new york
state large uh dairy farm as a matter of
fact uh he comes to church late some
morning because he's got to milk his
college before he gets out he gets that
he better
yeah you've got to you can't let those
cows sit around all day uh with all that
milk um
and
he doesn't have any problem i don't
think anybody in church has any problems
so i don't see any prohibition per se
for clean animals uh particularly if
you're trying to raise them healthily uh
helpfully as as this elder is
in that church you know maybe i can
share
an item of information i worked in
colombia for many years
and colombia is a very
highly productive country when it comes
to coffee
and some individuals that have become
adventists have huge coffee
farms and what they have done
is that they have changed
the crop
that they grow
in other words instead of coffee they
grow plantains and bananas and other
things in other words they change the
crop
others
simply sell
their their land
and they go into another line of
business
but of course coffee is in a different
category because it's a poison yes you
know it's uh it actually ruins your
nervous system so it's not the same as
uh as what the question is being asked
here but you know
my point is if it troubles you to the
point that it appears it troubles him
it probably god is trying to tell him
something and maybe he should pray to
the lord and ask the lord to show him
what to do yes whether to change the
business you know to something else
maybe growing crops
but it's something that god has directly
to direct him to do yeah i i think your
point is well taken if you are troubled
in your spirit if the lord
is is is moving in your heart and you
feel
uh uneasy about something then then
jettison it you know get rid of it so
it's not between you and the lord
because
when the lord told the rich young girl
to get rid of all your money and come
and follow me that was not a
prescription for poverty for the for the
church it was his problem that he had to
deal with right and that was a solution
to his problem so sometimes because of
how you were born how you were raised
what things you've gone through the lord
may be saying for you
this is not something you need to be
involved in you need to jettison this
from your life right but that may not be
a prescription for every every adventist
yeah in the light of what ellen white
states that the time will come when it
will be necessary to totally discard
flesh foods
uh you know maybe the lord is attempting
to tell this person you know now is
probably the time to think about
transitioning into something else but
the lord has to guide in that decision
we cannot dictate that decision because
it's not directly addressed in the bible
okay here's another question uh this one
is very interesting i've had this
question asked before
exodus 40
versus
20 to 30
talks about the arrangement of the
sanctuary furniture
verse 21 says the ark is the only
article in the most holy compartment
hebrews 9 1-7
lists the arrangement differently
putting the golden censer
and the ark
in
the most holy compartment in verse four
please explain
this
mistake well it's an assumption that
it's a mistake uh you know that there's
a discrepancy between uh the ark uh
being in the most holy place the only
article in the most holy place
and uh the golden censor uh being
in the uh hebrews chapter nine verse one
through seven speaking about the golden
censor and the ark in the most holy
compartment so i guess the question is
wasn't the sensor really something that
was uh used at the altar of incense in
the holy place
rather than the sensor being in the most
holy place i think that that probably is
the gist of the question
even having said that
it would not be counted as a piece of
furniture
uh you know what else is in the in the
most holy place
um
the law of moses which is in the side of
the ark but that's not counted as a
separate piece of furniture it's called
as counted as part of
the ark itself right you know so um
i don't see a discrepancy there in in in
in
having the censor there at all
yeah um
you know i've dealt with this question
very very uh frequently people ask that
question people who are well versed in
the study of scripture
and
you know even though the altar of
incense was in the holy place
its orientation was toward the most holy
place
because when the incense was offered
true it went up the up the veil yeah and
the the veil was embroidered with angels
which means that the angels take our
prayers to god and bring back answers
from god and so the smoke would go up
the veil and it would go into the most
holy place
so
so even though the the piece of
furniture was in the holy place
actually its orientation
was towards the most holy place
another important detail that we need to
take into account
is that
jesus as our intercessor which is
represented as the
as the golden altar
jesus is our intercessor but we need to
remember that jesus served
as high priest in the holy place until
1844. yes and then he moved into the
most holy place
he continues his intercessory work in
the most holy place
so the ark so in other words the the
golden altar of incense
plays a function in the holy place and
it also has a function in the most holy
place when jesus goes in there because
in 1844 jesus did not cease the work of
the holy place he simply added an
additional function
which is the judgment in the most holy
place very true so i think for those two
reasons number one it's orientation
towards the most holy place
and the fact that jesus ministers as
intercessor before 1844 in the holy
place but then he offers the incense of
his merits in the most holy place
might explain the reason why there's an
apparent discrepancy although it's not
really a discrepancy at all which is why
that altar is at that at the end of the
holy place towards the most holy place
just before the veil right so it uh it
has that dual function right that's a
very good uh very good so i think that
that probably would be
the answer uh we only have like uh four
minutes left
so let me see if i can find a question
here that we can deal with
uh quickly let's do uh the last one that
you have there
which uh questions on fiery column
versus the egyptian army
some big lettering at the top fiery
conversation there we go
so this is uh what the individual writes
since the fiery column that god placed
between israelites and the pursuing
pursuing egyptian army was indeed
a column
presumably not too wide well that's a
problem already he's saying presumably
not too wide then why is it that the
egyptians didn't simply go around it
to get to the israelites even if that
would involve them splitting their army
in two or more groups as the column
perhaps presumably would not then split
up or widened to block all of these
subdivisions
why not because that's not the way it
happened
you know
the bottom line is that if you read
patriarchs and prophets it says the
entire encampment of the egyptians was
in darkness yes and the entire
encampment of the israelites was in
light
so it was not merely a column in the
middle that they could go around right
he's thinking of a pillar
like a pillar holds up a roof or
something yeah
this was much bigger much broader yeah
and the pillar went backwards
and even though the pillar was still a
pillar the darkness yes was all
embracing yes and so uh you know the
bottom line is that the bible tells us
that was darkness for the egyptian it
was light for god's people yeah ellen
white amplifies uh the fact that the
egyptians were not able to cross the
darkness into the realm of light
this is superseding what would happen
naturally in nature this is something
very very special
that god was doing that should have been
a warning to the to the egyptians but
they didn't they didn't pick up on it uh
the dark the column was
god ordained and the darkness was god
remained this is not a normal situation
so to try to
see it in totally
human terms or or man-made mechanical
terms sort of does violence to what the
lord is doing here yeah by the way the
the story is found in exodus chapter 14.
um
let's see if we can find the specific
uh the specific verses here
it says in verse 19
if you want to read that exodus 14 verse
through verse 20.
okay
there we are
and the angel of god who went before the
camp of israel moved and went behind
them i remember this from the spirit of
prophecy he says that the pillar went
around behind them
uh
right and the pillar of cloud went uh
from before them and stood behind them
so it came between the camp of the
egyptians and the camp of israel so
these are not normal movements right
there's something very special is
happening thus it was a cloud and
darkness to the one
and they gave light by night to the
other so that the one did not come near
the other all that night so i think it's
pretty clear you know
it might be academic to say why they
didn't go around well the fact is the
bible says that they didn't right and
they were not able to yeah
so i think that we just need to stick
with the biblical testimony on this
particular one
yeah that line presumably not too wide
well don't presume that no we can't
can't make presumptions
okay well our time basically is up and
uh we have just a few seconds left we
want to thank you for tuning in to this
program live program it airs every
tuesday 4 30 in the afternoon pacific
standard time thank you for sending your
questions once again the place to send
them is tv at some tv.org we'll do the
research do everything possible to
answer your questions god bless you
and please join us at our next program
i'd like to know
[Music]
you